all right my friends so i said yesterday
we would be talking about
this today so let's just jump right into
it because it's a big topic and
and a scary one quite frankly the
question
is does it appear as though we are
barreling towards
a second violent insurrection
sometime in the month of august now
let's discuss that
first of all why are we even talking
about august we're talking about august
because the washington post
and the new york times and the national
review
a conservative leading outlet have
published articles over the last couple
of weeks outlining to different degrees
donald trump's belief or hope that he
will be reinstated as president of the
united states
sometime in august of this year meaning
in just a couple of months
now as you know and as i know that is
impossible
you and i know that reinstatement is not
a process that is part of the american
system of government
there is a president there is a vice
president if for some reason the
president is no longer president
the vice president becomes the president
there is a line of succession
none of it includes we go back to the
previous guy
who lost an election it doesn't work
that way the next presidential election
is november of 2024 whoever wins will be
inaugurated in january of 2025 but that
doesn't matter
to donald trump and apparently it
doesn't matter to millions of his
followers around the country
who are increasingly convinced
increasingly waiting for
their fearless leader to be quote
reinstated
by the time that summer is over there
was a really good post on our subreddit
that for some reason was since
deleted by the person who posted it and
it asked potential august insurrection
is it being overlooked and the subreddit
user pointed out
they've been hearing from family in
rural missouri
they've been hearing from family in
rural wisconsin and
many of them are quote stocking up on
ammunition
and firearms for what is maybe coming in
august
they talk about trump's supposed
generals that he has on his side and
their expectation that there's going to
be an attempt
to take joe biden out of the white house
and put trump in
sometime during august and the post
pointed out
something that's pretty astute which is
that the public-facing media story has
been oh
mike flynn talking about there should be
a coup
and donald trump continuing to say the
election was stolen and we must do these
audits and trump's saying i will be
president again sooner than you
think but to people thinking about that
below the surface
there is an incredibly irrational group
of people
who believe that that is a code directed
to them
that they should be ready to take up
arms against the government and sadly
in practice it may be functioning as
such a code whether that's what donald
trump intends or not it doesn't even
matter
in practice it very well may function as
a code in that sense
our viewer wrote that many of the people
that he's talking about aren't hugely
visible
online but they are quietly stocking up
ammunition
acquiring firearms and preparing to do
the worst if the time should come they
point out
that the rhetoric they are seeing on
signage in rural missouri and rural
wisconsin
has gotten crazier you know about dead
democrats being the only good ones and
other
violent messages so the question is
whether the possibility
of serious violence in august is being
overlooked
i believe it's important not to be
hyperbolic uh i still think the most
likely situation is when trump doesn't
become president
in august uh not much violence will
happen
certainly no big organized violent event
and they'll go and focus on november
or the next january or whatever the case
may be
that's what i think is the most likely
outcome and they'll put in place some
new arbitrary timeline
to look forward to but there is
precedent for these violent riots and
the precedent was five months ago when
on january 6th
trump riots took place in washington d.c
and we are still going through what are
now i think 450 different
uh court cases as a result so what we
can hope
is that these folks that our viewer is
seeing in missouri and wisconsin and
elsewhere number one or on the radar
of law enforcement if you come across
someone
you believe is planning to do violence
notify local law enforcement
notify the fbi the fbi is taking this
seriously and number two
for the ones that are determined to do
violence
hopefully it just won't be convenient
for them to get themselves to washington
dc
it's it's horrible to have to count on
that
but to some degree i think it will be a
factor that dissuades some of them as
well so i share the concern with you
at many times in history even talking
about is it possible
that the former president who has
continued to claim he actually won
will lead a riot in the middle
of another president's term in order to
try to oust that president in in many
times in american history it would be
crazy to even bring this up
sadly right now um
this has changed irreversibly because of
what happened in january
we now have to take this possibility
seriously
and uh it is a real possibility that
they may do more of it and so we're
going to continue following it
we are continuing to see what is the
totality of what we're seeing
we're seeing what donald trump is saying
of course
we are starting to see um an escalation
in the violent rhetoric from simply
republican voters
we are starting to see both online and
offline rhetoric
become more radical we are hearing from
people
coded language like we're going to get
the white house back
sooner than you think when it's like
well you could get it back in november
of 2024 that's the soonest
but they're they're going beyond that in
the way that they're hinting and
fainting so
that's f-e-i-n-t uh so unfortunately
i share this concern i hope that there
is no violence in august but i worry
that something is building here and if
so
i do hope law enforcement is aware of it
if you ever feel
like you just don't have enough time to
read all the books you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book
or audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit
a book you've already read or use it to
preview a book
before you buy the full version and read
it i recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great stephen
hawking this is a book that i have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
8 bucks a month and you get the entire
library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video